bonsoir nous sommes le mercredi 2 mars
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal comme
chaque jour nous revenons sur votre
actualité locale entouré de nos invités
également des journalistes de la
rédaction tout de suite on commence avec
les titres de cette édition
10e édition de la semaine de la femme à
magny les hameaux pour l'occasion la
ville a choisi de mettre à l'honneur les
peuples nomades depuis hier l'estaminet
accueille une exposition sur les himbas
peuple donné mission et deuxième épisode
de notre série consacrée aux yvelinois
présent au salon de l'agriculture
aujourd'hui reportage sur la ferme de
viltain située à jouy en josas depuis 28
ans son équipe prend sont des vaches du
salon et notamment de leur alimentation
et c'est un sport originaire des états
unis le tumbling est une discipline
affilié à la fédération française de
gymnastique
découvrez avec nous ce sport où les
athlètes doivent enchaîner des accords
des acrobaties sur une piste 2 25 m de
long et nous vous en parlions hier la
grève des salariés de la plateforme xp
au logistique attrape un accord a
finalement été trouvé mardi tard dans la
nuit entre la direction du groupe auchan
et des salariés de xp au logistique
aujourd'hui le groupe a communiqué sur
le fait que les représentants du
personnel et les salariés ont été
informés que le client donc le groupe de
distribution garantit le maintien de 80
% des volumes traités par xp ou
logistique sur site ce qui permet de
garantir tous les emplois en cdi sur la
durée du contrat de prestations en cours
ces engagements seront confirmées lors
d'une réunion de comité extraordinaire
est prévu vendredi prochain et le
mouvement social qui perturbait
fortement le trafic des seize lignes
desservant vélizy et une partie de
versailles depuis le 22 février est à
présent terminée rappelez vous la
semaine derrière les élus avait même
conduit des minibus pour transporter les
usagers pendant cette grève le syndicat
et la direction de fébus keolis ont
trouvé un accord après plusieurs jours
de négociations autour de la question
des salaires notamment
le trafic était assuré à 80% mardi et la
reprise sera totale ce mercredi selon la
direction
et pour sa dixième édition de la semaine
de la femme magny les hameaux a choisi
de mettre à l'honneur les peuples
nomades
durant quinze jours de nombreuses
animations sont pros
ces ateliers projections ou encore
rencontrent depuis hier l'estaminet
accueille une exposition sur les himbas
un peuple de namibie c'est mélanie poker
qui vous l'a fait découvrir le rouge
c'est celui de l'offre dont ce peuple
sans lui les himbas peuple semi-nomade
de la libye sont à l'honneur de la
semaine de la femme mme annick oise chez
les himbas c'est une société matriarcale
et l'héritage se transmet par les femmes
c'est un peuple aussi qui lutte vraiment
pour sa survie
et enfin pour sa survie au sens
étymologique du terme c'est-à-dire
culturellement ils sont confrontés avec
la société moderne
le développement du tourisme en ali et
c'est garder au maximum sa structure
familiale
plongée au coeur des traditions des
coutumes de ce peuple
cette exposition présentée pour la
première fois en 2008 est à l'initiative
d'une femme une française
solenn bardet ethnologue et géographe
elle avait 18 ans elle est partie seule
en afrique elle y est restée deux ans
auprès du peuple himba elle a même été
adoptés dont par par khadidja une femme
qui va devenir plus tard chefs de tribus
et depuis c'est elle qui est le porte
parole au niveau occidental et devenus
de ce peuple qui risque d'être en voie
de disparition
l'exposition est à découvrir au café de
l'estaminet jusqu'au dimanche 13 mars
une visite guidée est organisée le 9
mars prochain
de quoi plonger un peu plus en terre
inconnue est à présent le deuxième
épisode de notre série sur le salon de
l'agriculture des dizaines de stands
évinois se sont installés samedi dernier
au salon de l'agriculture porte de
versailles à paris
parmi eux la ferme de viltain de jouy en
josas situé à seulement 17 kilomètres de
la porte de versailles
c'est cette ferme qui prend soin des
vaches du salon et notamment de leur
alimentation
alors comment on s'organise t-il quel
est l'enjeu d'un tel salon pour les
exposants réponse avec annie bourdillon
et william l
300 vaches laitières sont présentes sur
le salon de l'agriculture
mais comment sont-elles nourris c'est la
ferme de viltain de jouy en josas qui en
a la lourde tâche pendant les 10 jours
d'exploitation du salon elle livre à
l'aube porte de versailles plus de 50
tonnes de ballots de maïs ce qu'on est
tout près de paris
tous les matins il ya 5 un camion qui
vient ramassé cinq tonnes de fourrage
pour les vaches du salon donc on cultive
plus de maïs parce qu'on sait que le
salon va avoir besoin de cette
nourriture en plus la ferme profite
aussi du salon de l'agriculture pour
mettre en valeur leurs aux animaux ici
deux petits veaux lille i et lille a
tout juste âgé de 4 mois
on va présenter la ferme
public francilien ça va être notre
notre clientèle beaucoup nous
connaissent déjà mais certains nous
jamais connu donc on a
a mis en place des vitrines pour faire
découvrir les produits
non
pour les visiteurs du salon venir goûter
ses produits c'est aussi l'occasion
d'échanger avec les agriculteurs et pour
eux c'est un moyen simple de mettre en
valeur leur savoir faire
car ici les produits sont vendus sans
intermédiaire directement de l'éleveur
aux clients une marge meilleure pour les
éleveurs et la qualité en plus
traçabilité du produit donc
tout bénéfice quant au monde pour
l'acheteur avec ses 350 animaux la ferme
de viltain produit plus d'un million de
litres de lait par an faisselle fromage
blanc et yaourts sont ensuite produits
et vendus sur place et demain troisième
épisode de notre série consacrée au
salon de l'agriculture il sera question
du restaurant monument de café situé à
versailles
il a fait une démonstration culinaire au
salon de l'agriculture reportage à
suivre demain et nous continuons sur
l'agriculture justement circuits courts
ou circuits de proximité acheter et
manger local c'est peut-être un des
nouveaux engagements citoyens
si on a l'image d'une région
ile-de-france urbanisées les habitants
de 50 ans début le savent les champs des
agriculteurs ne sont jamais très loin
pour nous en parler ce soir en plateau
avec nom mélanie poquet conçoit ram et
la méfiance rural et l'île de france est
même 49 % de sa surface qui est agricole
il y à plus de 5000 exploitation dans la
région tous secteurs confondus
tout à leur fera nous avait appuyé sur
le terme proximité alors faut savoir
qu'on peut manger local sans
nécessairement passer par un circuit
court sans qu'ils aient pas beaucoup
d'intermédiaires
jérôme comme le directeur du centre
régional de valorisation et d'innovation
agricole et alimentaire nous donne des
précisions
l'agriculteur qui est âpre en bas
envoient 300 bornes de paris qui vivre
chez son collègue qui validerait qui
ensuite va livrer des planchettes pis
pour passer trop d'intermédiaires
alors que ils méritent de libre est
aussi bien que le péruvien qui a un
bureau à rungis et en manar agissent et
réagissent doivent libre et les décors
ça fait la proximité est de plus en plus
plébiscités oui parce que selon le
ministère de l'agriculture et le cabinet
naturel marketing institute 71% des
français préfèrent acheter des produits
locaux
nous sommes allés à la rencontre des
visiteurs du salon de l'agriculture
pouvoir s'ils recherchent eux aussi le
commerce local g8 j'accompagne je vais
dans les faire directement
j'ai acheté la viande là où il
oui s'élèvent les ports les la viande de
boeuf là où ils élèvent les voeux ça
fait travailler les gens des régions
mais pourquoi parce que ces milieux
naturels et oui nous on est d'un peu de
la campagne donc on vend producteurs et
même dans notre jardin nous avons aussi
qu'il faut pour nous alimenter ses
demandes a complètement complètement bas
parce que c'est directement du
producteur au consommateur par quoi
enfin le bord des routes quand ils
vendent directement ou alors par chez
moi j'ai des gens qui ont des fermes
parce que j'habite à armandie donc on
l'a entendu elle est directement aux
producteurs à la ferme faire attention à
la provenance c'est ce qu'on vient
d'antan et cette volonté est aussi
ressentie par le cervia je pense le
consommateur aujourd'hui il est sans fil
à l'origine de tant premier est
l'origine de 100 produits
c'est pas le circuit court l'origine de
100 produits s'est produit vient et 30
km
lille ap trois intermédiaires pour le
consommateur c'est pas grave
par contre le même produit qui aurait
fait 3 bis km par un cerf intermediates
à boulder on a parlé du local mais il ya
aussi le circuit court est souvent le
salon de l'agriculture c'est le moyen
pour les agriculteurs de se faire
connaître pour favoriser donc la
proximité et c'est le cas de la ferme de
viltain on en a parlé tout à l'heure
elle est située à jouer en josas leur
activité principale c'est donc le lait
ils élèvent leur bétail font l'attrait
transforme le relais qui vendent ensuite
dans leurs boutiques
donc ce salon de l'agriculture ils
rencontrent leurs clients professionnels
mais aussi les particuliers
on va présenter la ferme au public
francilien ça va être notre
notre clientèle beaucoup nous
connaissent déjà mais certains noms
jamais connu donc on a
a mis en place des vitrines pour faire
découvrir les produits ça fait 28 ans
qu'on est ici tous les ans e
chaque année on a un stand différent
pour nous c'est vraiment très importante
et en toute bienveillance on est on est
vraiment très content d'être ici et
présenter notre notre ferme notre
concept mode cueillette la laiterie donc
on l'a vu une année les agriculteurs
cherchent à se faire connaître
et si nous justement particuliers ou
cherchent à consommer local et qu'on ne
sait pas où trouver les produits est ce
que vous avez quelques pistes à nous
donner alors si vous souhaitez fort à
vous de venir local locavore vous pouvez
favoriser le commerce du coin l'artisan
le boucher vous pouvez aussi le
sensibiliser à se fournir auprès de
producteurs locaux
vous pouvez vérifier les étiquettes des
produits que vous souhaitez acheter et
le cervia dont on parlait tout à l'heure
a lancé mangeons local en ile de france
il référence beaucoup de produits et
sept produits sont identifiées par un
logo
il y à un deuxième site ou sur lequel on
peut aller voir c'est le ministère de
l'agriculture qui lui référence beaucoup
d'initiatives locales
merci beaucoup mélanie et pour
rencontrer les agriculteurs locaux vous
avez aussi tirer jusqu'à ce dimanche
donc le 6 mars pour vous rendre au salon
de l'agriculture afin de leur poser
toutes vos questions
autre thème à présent nous sommes
toujours en vacances pour la zone c lors
des vacances scolaires vous faites
peut-être partie de ceux qui confient
leurs enfants à des centres de loisirs
et à des animateurs ces derniers sous
formé en amont est diplômée d'un bafa le
brevet d'aptitude à la formation d'
animal d'animateurs pardon de nombreuses
communes et centres de formation propose
des stages depuis samedi 18 juin à saint
quentinois se sont lancés dans la
première partie de leur bafa nous sommes
allés à manier les mots voir à quoi
ressemble justement cette formation
regardé et je dois enlever ce qui va
partir j'en apprends un chamboule tout
pour retrouver les produits de la paella
cet après midi la formation de ces
futurs animateurs c'est grand jeu avec
ateliers stands
jean-luc travaillent déjà dans
l'animation mais il profite de ce stage
pour renforcer son bagage professionnel
il ya beaucoup plus de responsabilités
qu'on pense parce qu'il faut dire ce qui
est basse et les enfants c'est des
enfants de parents qu'on donne ou bien
encore savoir créer un cadre et un jeu
travailler en équipe certains des
stagiaires sont encore mineurs ils
apprennent donc aussi à se
responsabiliser et comprendre le public
accueilli c'est très dense parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de théorie avoir la
connaissance de l'enfant la sécurité la
réglementation comment s'organise une
journée sur un accueil de loisirs
séjours de vacances mais aussi il faut
apprendre à tester des techniques et
puis à se créer sa petite trousse à
outils d'animateurs âgés de 17 à 26 ans
et stages et aux huit jours pour
apprendre les bases du métier
à l'issue de cette session si elle est
validée par l'équipe encadrante
ces jeunes pourront s'occuper d'enfants
de 3 à 17 ans lors de leur stage
pratique et peut-être sur magny les
hameaux
le service jeunesse de la commune les
accompagnons dans leurs recherches et
nous parlons à présent ce soir emploi et
social avec l'association cbl réagir
nous accueillons en plateau avec nous
rené karthala président de l'association
ou bonsoir et merci d'être venus et
mylène dewilde agents d'insertion
bonsoir à vous plus également alors
votre association est un intermédiaire
des aides aux chômeurs à les accompagner
vers l'emploi
depuis maintenant plus de 20 ans et vous
venez d'ouvrir une antenne à saint cyr
l'école
pourquoi justement avoir décidé d'ouvrir
une antenne sur notre territoire bien
l'origine l'association a été créée sur
la celle saint cloud c'est un peu le
résultat d'une révolte de citoyens qui
sont dit il faut faire quelque chose
contre le chômage et soit chef dans
l'ancien change d'entreprise ou jeunes
retraités ils ont démarré ya une
vingtaine d'années sur la
celle-saint-cloud bougival marly et
avec une seule salariée à l'époque
quatre cinq bénévoles
maintenant aujourd'hui nous sommes six
salariés et une vingtaine de bénévoles
sur un territoire qui vient de
s'agrandir par la direction du travail
dans les yvelines nous a demandé au mois
de dur au 1er novembre de reprendre tout
un grand un immense territoire de 120
mégabits temps qui va de saint cyr
l'école jusqu'à mon bon chartrain en
passant par plaisir les clayes-sous-bois
alors vous accompagnez justement à les
chômeurs vers la recherche d'emploi vers
l'emploi
comment ça se passe très pratiquement un
millier de villes de caen ils viennent
justement à dans votre antenne
alors les demandeurs d'emploi nous sont
envoyées en général par pôle emploi ou
les mairies ou les travailleurs sociaux
donc nous les accueillons et nous
étudions l'heure
leur situation par un examen approfondi
ensuite nous évaluer à doser ils ont une
évaluation de leurs compétences avec nos
responsables techniques et enfin nous
validons leur inscription en réunion il
y à une sélection s'est passé sur la
base de la motivation non au début c'est
sur la base des compétences c'est par là
que c'est par là que tout commence
et ensuite nous nous les mettons nous
les mettons en mission chez des
particuliers pour du service à la
personne ou pas mais aussi j'ai dans des
entreprises des collectivités locales
des résidences des mairies parallèlement
au bout de deux ou trois mois de deux
missions effectives nous leur proposons
un accompagnement au cours duquel nous
étudions leurs projets leurs projets
professionnels
nous leur proposons exact mais également
des formations qualifiantes
si si besoin est et puis ensuite nous
les aidons à la recherche d'un emploi
pérenne alors comment ça se passe
justement avec les particuliers et les
entreprises que les nerfs les quotités
font appel à vous du côté des voulés
solliciter les mairies les entreprises
et les particuliers pour qu'ils
accueillent alors les particuliers notre
méthode est effectivement de communiquer
auprès d'eux en ce qui concerne ce
nouveau territoire
nous avons fait une distribuer tracts
âge une distribution de tracts dans
toutes les boîtes aux lettres de saint
cyr l'école les clayes-sous-bois plaisir
et caetera et ça donnait un résultat
immédiat c'est à dire on croule sous les
appels
dans la peine à faire face à toutes ces
demandes et le particulier qui a besoin
soit d'une aide ménagère soit deux
volets de le bouton va bientôt arriver
de jeannette jardiniers ont cherché
d'abord à bien comprendre son besoin de
façon à lui dire si on est capable de
répondre positivement et à ce moment là
de le garantir une qualité de compléter
enfin une coupe et les compétences est
quelqu'un de confiance
on ne va pas chez un particulier comme
ça je pensais la différence avec ce
qu'un particulier peut trouver par un
réseau des changes qui existe dans
toutes les villes maintenant où là on
peut rire de voir arriver un peu
n'importe qui l'a nous servons
d'intermédiaires comme il vient de le
dire la personne on l'a déjà reçu
plusieurs fois on l'a déjà fait
travailler et donc on sait que ça se
passera bien si la demande a bien été
précisé il s'avère que dans certains cas
l'expérience a montré qu'il fallait
aller sur place
on envoie des bénévoles vérifie
compétents vérifier sur place avant
d'envoyer quelqu'un si on a bien compris
la demande et les difficultés
éventuelles on le festivent
systématiquement pour tout ce qui est
jardinage et travaux techniques sa der
faire une salle de bains ou un séjour
on va voir sur place si c'est trop
difficile parce que momentanément on n'a
pas forcément le professionnel capable
on le dit tout de suite on dit
adressez-vous art
le cas d'autres entreprises mais nous on
peut pas si on peut on le on le fait on
ne fournit pas un doji au sens classique
du terme ont fait une évaluation du
temps de travail nécessaire parce que
nous mettons à disposition
nous restons employeurs des personnes
nous mettons à disposition des personnes
sous la surveillance du client en va du
particulier qui doit dire exactement ce
qu'il veut qui achète le matériel si
nécessaire nous nous fournissons que
debra compétent est bon alors pour des
entrepôts alors pour adoration pour les
particuliers comme les particuliers
alors pour les particuliers faire
dresser annonçait d'une part avoir une
garantie qu on envoie quelqu'un qui a
été sélectionné on est moins cher que le
travail non dissimulé en ce qui concerne
le service à la personne grâce à la
défiscalisation et pour les travaux on
est évidemment nettement moins cher
qu'une entreprise
le bilan économique
il peut se faire que le la paire notre
intervenant sont un peu moins rapide que
un travailleur d'une entreprise
donc il faut peut-être ça la grande
conscience et l'écart de salaires du
tarif est telle que le client est
largement pavant et le troisième raison
de train pour faire appel à nous c'est
effectivement un acte citoyen c'est de
faire travailler un demandeur d'emploi
de preuves disons 2 de l'environnement
local
alors miley ne va que vous occupez vous
êtes à l'antenne donc de sincère combien
de personnes vous encadrez un petit peu
comment ça se nous avons à peu près à
l'heure actuelle 45 personnes
d'inscrites qui son ambition qui sont en
mission
on en a encore beaucoup d'autres qui
sont en attente sur listes d'attentes
parce que nous devons malheureusement
pour eux attendre les demandes des
clients
mais actuellement nous avons sur les 45
une vingtaine de personnes qui sont en
mission très régulière et 20 autres qui
sont en mission ponctuelle vous
substituer un petit peu à pôle emploi
finalement alors on est complémentaires
on est complémentaire avec pôle emploi
qui normalement doit nous envoyer des
demandeurs d'emploi qui veulent
travailler rapidement parce que nous
nous procurons des missions très
rapidement c'est pas évidemment trouver
un cdi ça va prendre plus de temps on va
mettre on a quand même un taux de retour
à l'emploi de 80% mais ça prend un an
voire deux ans pour que la personne ne
finisse par trouver ce qu'elle souhaite
c'est un train travail à temps plein en
cdi
ça ça prend du temps mais en attendant
on va leur trouver des missions est la
nôtre grande différence avec pôle emploi
c'est que le diagnostic nous pouvons
porter sur les personnes et sur non pas
du déclaratif
mais puisque on les fait travailler et
que dès la première mission on demande
un retour d'expérience auprès du
particulier ou de la mairie ou de
l'entreprise savoir comment ça s'est
passé
on peut corriger le tir si nécessaire
immédiatement et donc après pour
travailler sur un parcours professionnel
on c'est notre devoir de dire à
certaines personnes vous rêvez vous
rêvez vous visez tel tel métier bon
actuellement il vaudrait mieux revoir et
à être réaliste et revoir votre projet
etc
c'est notre métier d'être ramené les est
par contre de les pousser à se former on
le retrouve des formations on trouve
l'organisme de formation on trouve le
financement auprès de pôle emploi
donc on est un peu sous traitant si l'on
peut dire de pôle emploi avec des
méthodes de travail différentes
alors justement un milieu si on veut se
rendre à l'antenne de saint cyr si on
veut voilà bénéficier de votre
accompagnement comment comment on fait
qu'elles sont issues les démarches
il a juste à se rendre oui un coup de
fil on prend rendez vous on donne aux
personnes au téléphone la liste des
papiers qu'ils doivent qu'ils doivent
apporter pour pour une inscription on
leur explique
on s'efforce quand même de savoir qu'ils
ont bien compris qu'ils nous étions quel
était le but de l'association est
ensuite y viennent nous prenons rendez
vous et là nous procédons à
l'inscription
et c'est là que nous que nous étudions
leur situation leur situation que nous
les adressons au responsable technique
pour voir s'ils ont vraiment bien les
compétences et que nous nous acceptons
leur la validation de leur de leur
inscription
j'aimerais vous faire juste de réagir
parce que l'entretien s'achève bientôt à
une dernière actualité
on parle beaucoup en ce moment du projet
de loi qui est très décrié donc donc la
loi du travail elle comrie de la
ministre du travail
vous pensez que c'est une bonne chose
vous avez voilà une bonne analyse des
personnes qui elles recherchent du
travail les chômeurs je vais répondre
avant je voulais réagir ce qui vient de
10 et vous répondez d'avoir médecin car
alors on a cherché ce que j'aime bien
torrent la loi et le cow boy
bon il se trouve juste changé de
casquette je trouve je suis en même
temps enfin j'ai été récemment élu
président de l'union nationale des
actions intermédiaire pour la france
entière et à ce titre j'ai écrit 3
février myriam el khomri pour lui faire
des propositions techniques nous
concernant et concernant les salariés
que nous faisons travailler alors elles
portent à la fois suivre une de demander
à pôle emploi de nous envoyer un peu
plus de demandeurs d'emploi de catégorie
a qui n'ont pas du tout travaillé nous
nous les ferons passer en catégorie b ou
sont instantanément
deuxièmement c'est de mu utiliser les
crédits
alloués à la formation professionnelle
nous cotisons en tant qu'employeurs et
nous pouvons nous sommes freinés dans
l'utilisation pour différentes raisons
exemple le contrat de
professionnalisation pour lequel nous
cotisons les demandeurs d'emploi que
nous on travaille et n'y ont pas accès
parce qu'un contrat de
professionnalisation suppose un cdd de 6
mois et une part consacré à la formation
de 25% nous donc ça veut dire 75% payées
par l'employeur
on travail normal nous n'en sort aucune
association intermédiaire n'en est
capable il faudrait qu'il y ait un
partage de 50% du temps en formation et
50% en travail dans l'entreprise
ça nous pourrions ou quelqu'un on
ouvrirait le champ du contrat de
professionnalisation ou à nous salariés
ce que nous souhaitons que là le genre
de suivre propositions que nous venons
de faire au ministre très bien merci
beaucoup d'avoir répondu à notre cahier
à nos questions et la tenir notre
plateau alors voilà si vous souhaitez
avoir plus d'informations sur ces belles
réagir sachez que leurs sites internet
s'affiche en bas de votre écran voilà
n'hésitez pas à regarder pour avoir plus
d'informations et un mot de sport à
présent aujourd'hui tv fil 78 vous
propose de découvrir le thème bling ce
sport originaire des états unis est une
discipline affilié à la fédération
française de gymnastique et un blur donc
ceux qui pratiquent ce sport doivent
enchaîner des acrobaties sur une piste
de 25 mètres de long
regardez ce reportage de mickael miro et
fanny bourdillon
ces sportifs jouent avec les lois de la
pesanteur le tumbling discipline au
programme des jo de 1932 à los angeles
est un dérivé de la gymnastique
l'objectif les tome leur doivent
enchaîner huit acrobaties consécutive
sur le piste de 25 mètres de long pour
séduire les juges en déplaçant en
arrière ça monte très haut ça voilà
entre autres essences il ya des
rotations en vrille ou ans à taux nul ya
une recherche du prise de vitesse
le support est beaucoup plus élastique
donc une amplitude plus grande donc
entre la gym et
et le tome la différence je dirais c'est
le temps d'un combat c est beaucoup plus
grande mine parce qu'on montre beaucoup
plus haut à la différence de la gym
seuls les contacts avec les pieds et
avec les mains sont autorisés avec la
vitesse les thèmes leur de maîtriser
leurs figures pour ne pas se blesser
attention j'ai eu d un peu des problèmes
aux articulations mais quand
quant aux s'échauffent après ça va quand
on voit comme ça tout le monde pense que
cette technique est très dangereuse mais
je vous dis si elle est faite avec
précaution c'est à dire que dire aux
enfants les dangers
les risques ne pas faire n'importe quoi
dire le d'entraîneur ça c'est important
après l'accident peut arriver le
département des yvelines contre 99
licenciés répartis dans trois clubs
affiliés à la fédération française de
gymnastique
ce chiffre représente près de dix pour
sonder tumblr présents dans l'hexagone
à présent la fin de cette édition mais
avant de nous quitter je propose de
regarder ces quelques images vous avez
dû le voir cet après midi aux alentours
de 16 heures la neige a remplacé la
pluie le temps d'une averse en raison
d'une baisse rapide des températures sur
saint quentin en yvelines et partout en
ile-de-france une courte chutes de neige
qui n'a pas tenu sur les routes
le temps restera assez instable les
prochains jours et des averses sont
attendues pour le week-end c'est à
présent la fin de cette édition merci
nous avoir suivis tout de suite vous
retrouvez sephora namani pour un nouveau
numéro de kiosques quant à moi je vous
retrouve demain je vous souhaite donc
une excellente soirée